[Musique]
frédéric del piro bonjour vous êtes
bonjour pdg de total linux et d'yttrium
alors on va d'abord parlé de total hilux
total linux et of fournisseur de
matériel informatique si vous allez vite
exactement régler totalement fait c'est
une société qui a un certain âge ça fait
à peu près à 81 02 mai 2004 donc à peu
près 18 ans 20 ans qu'on existe
on fournit des datacenters notamment sur
toute la partie hp c'est donc à une
performance computing c'est la
fourniture de super calculateur pour
calculer des avions des voitures des
déformations quelle qu'elle soit voilà
que ça peut du risque financier aussi
suite à la faire par exemple kerviel et
éventuellement sur tout ce qui est
calcul de médicaments ou de vaccins
comme par exemple pour la copie de 19
mois donc on fournit ont fourni ce genre
de solution à un grand nombre de clients
quelle que soit l'heure leur verticale
nous sommes à jouy en josas qui le ciel
de total inc pourquoi d'où ça vient tout
à linux ça veut dire alors totale est
nul ça c'est une bonne question en fait
quand j'ai créé la société sade et en
2004 j'avais pas forcément beaucoup
d'idées et je venais d'un monde qui
s'appelait le monde d'unix unix et ans
l'ancêtre de linux mais unique c'était
un système exploitation payant qui était
développé par les constructeurs
informatiques qui était à l'époque hp
sun qui n'existe plus je crois qu'ils
avaient compaq et puis on avait un
quatrième que ebay et ils avaient chacun
cette exploitation qui s'appelait unix
avec un nom différent et un norvégien je
crois un étudiant a trouvé une bonne
idée il s'est dit pourquoi pas très
incités d'exploitation gratuit et il a
créé donc linux et il est associé x et
linux
il y associer une petite mascotte qui
est le pingouin donc c'est pour ça que
vous retrouvez vous retrouverez ci vous
pouvez sur nos anciens logos un pingouin
avec marc est totale linux extrême
confiance voilà alors on va parler de
libération ce qu'on va là bas le cool
calling immersion à 16 ans alors ils
version cooling on a surtout league
mais auparavant alors il faut de tête d
un état des lieux c'est vrai que des
datacenter ça consomme une énergie
incroyable
alors c'est un peu le problème que l'on
est en train de découvrir actuellement
avec les chiffres de 2020 qui vient de
tomber
les data center et deux sont devenus les
premiers pollueurs de la planète
premier pollueur les premiers pollueurs
devant les trois autres on était 4e en
quand j'étais dans l'aviation c'est pas
un an heureusement que kovy de
l'aviation à bien m'entraîner un les gaz
tout ce qui est en train de carbone a
diminué fortement les datacenter eux ont
augmenté pourquoi parce qu'en fait les
gens sont retrouvés chez eux à faire du
télétravail ce qui est très bien
évidemment à visionner des films en vod
etc etc donc à faire appel à de plus en
plus de ressources sur sur les data
center ou dans les datacenters mon cas
de la data à du transfert réseau et à
tout ce qui va avec a qu à faire des
commandes sur apam assure sur des
plateaux on va dire ah oui ce qui fait
ce serait a généré un énorme trafic et
demandez vite donc ça à gré non c'est
pas ça tellement et de gaza et donc les
pôles et data center sont faut le savoir
aujourd'hui sont des gros
consommateurs d'eau des consommateurs
d'eau douce et résistant à 600 millions
de données de 600 millions de mètres
cubes en coupe de l'aude ou aux doses il
va par an ça ne fait que s'empirer par
exemple vous avez un gars qui a
construit un datacenter au chili à
santiago du chili et consomment et
personnes par jour tenez vous bien 14
millions de litres d'eau pour refroidir
uniquement le matériel informatique
alors au chili l'eau potable c'est parce
qu'il ya de plus courant non de l'isère
des choix qu'on restait le problème de
l'eau va t'aider cholet mais sont alors
ces sociétés là ont un tel pouvoir
financier ils ont eu le droit de faire
des captations direct dans la nappe
phréatique et c'est ça qui est
aujourd'hui qui est déplorable c'est que
l'eau va devenir d'après l'onu en 2030
rats et en 2040 d'après le gartner va
devenir va disparaître sur certaines
zones du globe donc
donc il va falloir choisir un moment est
ce qu'on va continuer à refroidir à la
de manière classique les agressions de
haut avec de l'eau ou est ce qu'il va
faire changer notre technologie est
adaptée et bien cette techno pour éviter
de gaspiller de l'eau qui est plutôt
destiné à l'être humain
on n'a pas parlé des gaz à effet de
serre les gaz à effet de serre ça c'est
aussi quelque chose que dégagent les
data center et ça c'est très très
inquiétant
alors parlons de l'immersion coville
justement qui a été la solution que vous
prônez alors l'immersion calling qu'est
ce que c'est l'immersion calling
scénique lui manque une vieille
technologie qui est de refroidissement
liquide des équipements électriques
donc s'il faut savoir que edf le fait
par edf par exemple un bien d'autres qui
le font le fait depuis 1950 avec ces
transformateurs moyenne tension et haute
tension
il le fait via un pc vie qui s'appelle
le pyralène le pyralène à une
problématique donc c'est quelque chose
de synthétique
il a une drôle a dit que c'est qu'il est
extrêmement toxique d'accord toxique
pour la planète et pour tout son
environnement et ne serait-ce aussi que
dans sa fabrication
donc c'est pas une résolution bas salat
et et technologiquement pendant un
moment parce qu'on ne ferait pas faire
autrement mais on peut faire beaucoup
mieux
voilà et aujourd'hui on sait faire mieux
donc c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui total
luxe s'est lancé sur ce programme
yttrium pour construire un data center
de nouvelle génération complètement
disruptif par rapport aux systèmes de
refroidissement actuel où aujourd'hui
ont refroidi les datacenter par air
forcé et la reprise nous ont refroidi lé
certains pratiquent parent ce fameux
liquide donc éteint son appel un liquide
gtl gas to liquid raffiné par un peu
n'importe qui par total par chef importe
qui raffine heures mais évidemment est
ce ce liquide a deux caractéristiques
principales
c'est il est électrique forcément dire
écrit qu'est ce que ça veut dire celles
qui ne conduit pas électricité c'est pas
de loup on va forcément c'est quand même
mieux pour rihanna qui a fait des
étincelles dans sa baignoire avec ça et
puis de i les calories porter dans quel
reporter qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire qu'en fait on va transmettre
la chaleur récupérée au sein des
molécules dire de molécules la molécule
dans le liquide on va transmettre la
chaleur de manière à ce que la chaleur
se dissipe très très rapidement mais
sans perte de charge d'accord mais l'ol
a un inconvénient c'est que de l'eau
chaude vous la tenez chaude pas très
longtemps
dire que quand vous la faites transvaser
elle perd de sa saveur
alors que ce liquide là il va garder la
chaleur il va la transporter enfin l'on
voit un petit peu voilà donc voilà voilà
la solution une solution donc on immerge
les les serveurs sont entièrement
immergé on vous voyez ici vous avez donc
des des processeurs qui chauffe avec des
barrettes mémoires et puis tous les
composants électroniques qui sont
rattachés à se servir de ça c'est un
élément que vous trouvez un élément
classique que vous retrouvez dans tous
les datacenters et un serveur de
production
et ça marche pour tout le monde et
malgré marche pour tous types de
matériels il ya aucune modification à
faire si ce n'est retiré les
ventilateurs qui sont faits pour grasset
l'air maquillé fut rien soyons francs
refroidi par air non refroidis en
immersion
donc en fait le liquide vient on vous
l'avez compris un tout autour de tous
les composants physiques en vue du
serveur c'est absolument génial
donc on peut en plus récupérer un peu
alors j en effet le liquide arrive à
température ambiante
il est là il est il arrive par le bas et
à partir de là par convection naturelle
le liquide va se réchauffer parce qu'il
va ailleurs un transfert thermique qui
va se faire des radiateurs dans le
liquide et le liquide chaud va remonter
et via un système de bacs tampons qu'on
peut trouver dans un incident une
piscine va partir dans un échangeur et
la chaleur delta de température le delta
t va lui être récupérée est renvoyé dans
la ctn du bâtiment yttrium donc ça c'est
important alors c'est que la chaleur va
être récupérée pour les besoins des
trieurs
besoin de la palourde et trium justement
qu'est ce que c'est qu'être l'herbe il
triomphe c'est quoi atrium c'est un
nouveau bâtiment qu'on y avoir plaisir
de construire sur la commune de jouy en
josas voir le jour en 2022 qui va voir
si tout va bien c'est le copil a décidé
d'arrêter de nous enlever ça parce que
ça a beaucoup gêné le constructeur avec
qui nous travaillons donc si tout va
bien
septembre 2022 on nous risquons d'être
livrée de ceux de ce data center et de
ce bâtiment qui sera qui sera donc jouée
en jeu il sera à l'entrée du bourg josas
donc jouer aulas vous le savez est une
très belle commune qui est une belle
petite vallée avec sur la partie sud hec
et puis ben nous aurons alors nous
sommes pas de la hauteur de la chaussée
de mai nous aurons donc totale mais qui
sera l'entrée de lille nord sur la
commune de joe jonas et dancette yttrium
alors il y aura le siège de total innus
je suppose duravel il y aura l'immersion
des dates à saint-dié y aura toute une
partie data center y aura une partie de
bureau oui il sera connecté ou non au
datacenter ça les locataires pour voir
ce que vous allez vous allez on est vers
des bureaux on est dans des sociétés on
aura des surfaces disponibles à la
location pour des sociétés qui sont deux
préfets enfin on verra dans notre
activité c'est toujours plus sympa
travail entre nous ou des sociétés qui
auront besoin le bureau plus tôt on va
dire de haute qualité est plutôt bien
positionné par rapport à au plateau de
saclay par rapport à orly et à roissy et
c'est acceptable d'accra voilà il a été
pensé la recette est lancée par un
architecte donc mam star est ici
présentes qui qui a donc à dessiner ce
bâtiment en ligue 1 voilà on a eu pas
mal de deux des changes avec le
constructeur parce qu'en fait on a dû on
va dire à ménager certaines contraintes
dues à notre activité
voilà on est une entreprise française
oui à tout à fait non mais voilà on a le
cocorico derrière vous faites partie de
cette excellence française c'est bien de
célébrer non
c'est bien de dire ses 7 buts
aujourd'hui cette émission c'est
vraiment de communiquer et puis de voir
comment on peut faire bénéficier un
maximum de société ce type d'innovation
parce qu'aujourd'hui
là encore voyez amazon a prévu de
construire un data center à brétigny sur
orge et vous avez une levée de boucliers
qui est en train de montlhéry commencé
ct aujourd'hui tout le monde les gens
dans la région et ben ne veut pas ne
veulent pas de ce data center
aujourd'hui ils vont capter toute
l'électricité du point du coup parce que
c'est à dire que leurs besoins ou leurs
besoins nous à l'heure des yvelines qui
vont se monter vous allez avoir une
captation de l'eau potable etc
ça alors a contrario ça va faire des
emplois voilà mes mais on va polluer
donc voilà donc il va falloir choisir
vous parlez de joueurs josas de 2,9 et
de hec il ya aussi et il ya cette petite
sculpture lac est derrière vous il ya
aussi paris saclay qui est dans le
territoire tout à fait et c'est vrai que
tout ça et qui nous aident à cette
excellence de l'année qui nous aide qui
nous met en avant par rapport à tous nos
projets et par rapport à cette vraiment
technologique est totalement disruptive
par rapport aussi à d'autres data center
qui se montrent encore actuellement sur
cette ancienne technologie qui est elle
je dirais aujourd'hui très très
polluante bon ben c'est ça aujourd'hui
la problématique
alors on a plus qu'à croiser les doigts
pour espérer que des huiles 22 voile à
écouter pourra venir à l'inauguration
que vous viendrez avec grand plaisir
avec vos confrères et puis on vous
montrera en vrai vous rentrerez dans le
datacenter et vous verrez donc ces bacs
puisqu'en fait on n'est plus sous forme
d'armoires verticale on est sur des bacs
horizontaux et sur lequel on pourra au
début circuler une fois qu'il est rentré
en production sera obligée de fermer
c'est comme dans tout ça la senteur on
ne peut pas circuler cd soit s'ils sont
clos fermé et sécurisé merci beaucoup
aux frais avec dlp ou hervé bravo
[Musique]
marie hélène aubert la maire de jouy en
josas que vous êtes doit être fier
d'accueillir des pépites comme total
linux extrêmement fier extrêmement fier
parce que j'y est une ville qui s'est
engagé dans la transition écologique
énergétique depuis un moment déjà
puisque en 2016 on a été labellisé
territoire à énergie positive pour la
croissance verte donc normalement engagé
pour une autonomie énergétique en 2056
mais voilà il faut que tous les acteurs
du territoire s'engage aussi dans cette
démarche pour que ça fonctionne et on
parle beaucoup de transition écologique
on rénove nos bâtiments on les isole on
parle beaucoup je agriculture urbaine et
cetera nature en ville mais là on est
dans une autre une autre dimension bien
plus efficace si j'ai bien compris la
technologie de ce futur data center et
qui agit sur la planète à une échelle
beaucoup plus importante
mais puisque je risquais les data center
comme le disait frappez vous sortir des
plus grands pollueurs ses seins actuelle
non mais pollueurs consommateurs s'auto
voilà et des structures la pnl matériel
sur du matériel etc et donc il va y
avoir ce titre i yom qui va mettre fin
2022 si tout va bien vous allez faire en
sorte qu'il soit mettre à l'honneur dès
que je le peux très heureuse de
l'accueillir
ça va être vraiment une vitrine de la
technologie française tels que tel qu'on
l'aimé telle qu'on est fiers de la
vendre à l'étranger donc extrêmement
fiers d'accueillir et trium à jouy en
josas
et c'est bien qu'une ville comme jouer
en josas c'est à la fois la toile de
jouy c'est à dire la tradition est à la
fois la modernité avec total hynix et
yttrium vous avez tout compris tout
l'enjeu
merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]